hey everybody and welcome to a raunchy
ass wild ride with stevo this week we
have the director of jackass jeff
germain and oh boy
throughout this conversation it just
gets more and more crazy and by the end
of it it's the most explicit podcast
conversation we've ever recorded man
what a treat and i'm telling you if this
doesn't make you hard as a rock i know
what will baby it's called blue chew
tablets and i use them all the time man
i absolutely love them they are
delicious chewable tablets with the same
active ingredient as both viagra and
cialis
and for you to get them you don't have
to have an awkward visit to the doctor's
office in person no you go to
bluechew.com you consult with one of
their medical providers it's quick and
easy and then once you're ready boom
they send these tablets right to your
house and guess what i can get you an
entire month's supply
absolutely for free all you gotta pay is
five bucks for shipping that's right if
you go to bluechew.com
and use the promo code stevo you're
gonna get an entire month's supply of
these awesome boner tablets and i'm
telling you you're gonna have the best
time just use the promo code stevo a
whole month supply absolutely for free
just pay five dollars for shipping now
let's get into this raunchy conversation
yeah
let's do it i couldn't be more [ __ ]
excited about this
ladies and gentlemen jeff tremaine
yeah
dude okay of course you know scott
randolph yes of course we're without
paul briskey
[ __ ] first paul
tested pauses for coving oh [ __ ] man
what a [ __ ]
he's like i feel fine
so i'm walking out of here
yeah coughing tomorrow no no no no like
we're
we're both negative yeah i've not
tested positive for the virus once
man i swear
i think i had it before it got in that
like in december i got all this except i
never lost myself i have no idea but i
got really sick as i've been in december
before the shoot came out my uh
my one positive test was for antibodies
yeah actually i never did that i should
have done that just to find out but i
don't think even it was available how
many times you guys test each other for
jackass for every day
every [ __ ] day every day and then
yeah i was doing
three times a week during post and all
that so it's
and um
that's gonna add to the budget of
jackass four it's incredible how much
was it
i don't know the final number but it's
over a mill i think like just which
means a lot to us
no just the whole thing like
god i know a guy who
does like security he runs a security
company with the studios and stuff and
he pivoted during this and they just
print money
security company that did you know like
keeps a set secure and then this [ __ ]
pandemic hit and the studios need to now
do so much testing and he was all set up
he just had to do some classes and
switch pivot over to covet safety i'm
sorry not i mean
is a money maker man
an ex-girlfriend of mine got her medical
something and she's able to sell ppe's
and she was just flipping containers out
at sea for like 40 grand a pop yeah it's
like okay cool yeah have a buyer great
we'll get you so the first question that
i've got to ask is like how
the [ __ ] is this movie coming out
i don't know it's it's nerve-wracking to
see i mean it's crazy because you've got
that like the polar extremes of like
craziest covet ever and biggest box
office revenue ever happening
simultaneously no and that doesn't help
the case to push it because right and
you're also hearing that this one's not
as bad like it's just
they've shortened most big people have
shortened the window if you test
positive it's five days now cdc has done
it like nfl is doing it and then if you
test negative twice you're back in like
oh you gotta test negative twice huh i
think for the nfl i think that's what it
is um i don't know but the cdc doesn't
tell you that just there's a quarantine
is shrunk but that that that weekend
that spider-man did domestic opening of
253 million
it was a different week than than what
we're getting into i know i know yeah
it's it's nerve-wracking i don't know
you know we gotta we're each day just
[ __ ] yeah and um you know hey man
like i'm gonna do everything in my power
to
promote this movie and it's not gonna
hurt my feelings if i promote it you
know in the spring no we all
have vested reasons do we want this
thing to do well exactly but yeah like
it's worth it
what do you think about this i've said
candidly
that
that my
my feeling is that the best jackass
movie was number two just because
we were
in our heyday we were so reckless
everything was working we got away with
everything
and uh jackass 3d was way more
commercially successful
but i think without the phantom camera
the super slow motion the 3d without all
of that i don't know if it i i see
i think you're on this super radical
like you just like the ready to die [ __ ]
right yeah jackass 2 is ready to die
everyone is ready to die willing to die
it's the gnarliest one right right right
right uh
i love 3d i think 3d like what they all
have including what we just shot is the
the spirit of right this camaraderie and
the love of this group and it's got
plenty of gnarly in it but it's it's
really
about this i know you've said that to me
before that each one just has its own
different thing and then you don't know
that until after right you just like
you're not we're not aiming for anything
as we're making them we're just putting
the best [ __ ] in and like maybe
maybe my feeling about jackass 3d is
just that because i was newly sober
like i was just like uncomfortable in my
skin i hadn't found my voice i was just
like this sort of afraid emotional nerve
right like uh and and then on this one
that's not the case it was incredible
you were able to do 3d like yeah you
know that's a
remember i came in for a screening of
jackass forever like when it was in its
infancy and i walked out of there
thinking man like not even like the
crazy stunts like of course that's all
in there but just the way that i just
felt comfortable and just like just
throwing out lines just and you look at
it yeah
i'm so happy with it i think this movie
is so damn good thank you i i do too
it's [ __ ] i do too and it was against
all odds like
the fact that we pulled this one off
unbelievably good um so dude
let me i think the funniest story and
the hardest that we've ever laughed on
this podcast was with dave england
telling
the story about putting poop on your
door your hotel door hanger
because you peed on his teddy bear
no i peed the pistols out there
i came home and there was like i [ __ ]
grabbed the door handle was that in it
was france i think paris paris getting
ready to go to amsterdam yeah and uh
we're shooting we're like yeah shooting
jackass a tv show yep and uh
i go to my room and
[ __ ] grab the handle and like you got
[ __ ] i got [ __ ] on my hand
and so now i've gotta [ __ ] figure out
who did it it didn't take long to figure
it out like because you were with gooch
uh no i went and found goop right away
and like yeah because
was gooch was actually staying with dave
but de gooch didn't sell him out like
it's like right i just figured it out
quickly and
gooch let me in the room i had access so
uh and i i tried to [ __ ] in his luggage
so bad
i said i'm a gucci
ass gooch like i sat over his [ __ ]
luggage he was right there in the room
and i squatted and just tried to force
one out and i couldn't so
i just peed all over everything he had
yeah he was particularly upset because
he had bought a stuffed animal for his
and [ __ ] him
but that okay by the way i took this
[ __ ] out and then put it back in so he
wouldn't notice so like oh okay he would
have been safe giving that to his kid if
he sinks down it doesn't go up you know
what i mean i mean yeah dude you're
talking to the wrong but then he went
home like he got so chapped he was like
it wasn't just that he went home he
called the area and he canceled all our
flights and he called the airlines
cancelled all your flights cancelled all
your hotels i think he was able to do
that like how like
how on top of it are you
to be able to do like i never would
think to do that even if i was so mad
i couldn't i couldn't do it i would need
help doing that even if i came up with
the idea it's so funny man when i was a
little kid i called every hotel in the
yellow pages to meet motley crew and i
got my photo taken with nikki sixx and
tommy lee and then after that because
that was i was 13. for the rest of my
life my dad always said
if you could just apply yourself because
if you could just apply the the tenacity
if you could show the motivation that
you showed to meet motley crew then you
could do anything and like here with
dave if you could
right like
incredible you'd be the king of the
world tenacity and there's the
absolute motivated asshole-ness right to
do that was incredible
right yeah like yeah and and where's his
motivation like like think about that
like like
how
devolved we got after that like so
peeing in luggage back then was the
biggest
like the biggest violation you could do
to somebody like fast forward just a
year and a half and
we all know what each other's piss
tastes like
you know what i mean we all know like
it's gotten so bad like
like that's just where we were at the tv
show then right and you know that's
probably why you like
two the most because two was probably
the peak of just the
most rotten behavior possible
that was making us laugh at the time it
took so much more like everything in
jackass one wouldn't make jackass too or
a very few a little bit of it would but
right you know like for our gnarly
standard or our gross out or you know
what makes us laugh to what we do to
each other after the shooting goes down
you know i love the way you put that
ready to die they're ready to die bits
and we we have those in the numerator
yeah for sure like everyone stepped up
like if anything
like because here's i know already i'm
gonna get asked a million times what's
it like shooting a jackass maybe now
that you're so much older and very
clearly
the difference is
that
our bones break way easier and it
requires much less to knock us
completely unconscious
and it takes as long to wake up when we
are completely unconscious
i'd say that there's not that much
difference
right so it's it's good for the viewer
yeah and the spirit is like so [ __ ]
alive like it's so much just the
you can feel it the minute we just you
know we went into that test shoot it was
just like oh
why are we so nervous about this let's
just [ __ ] go i went and saw it and i
feel like this one when you you came
with me yeah i came with you to a screen
i feel like this one people were
emotionally breaking in certain bits
well
they've always done that too
but i feel like i feel like one two
three like it was like [ __ ] this one
they were like i've had it yeah i do i
had that this one made me laugh harder
than any of them yeah like the
my favorite thing in it is the silence
of the lamb spit where right uh
because it's so psychological and it's
so and we we paired everybody up to be
the right person it was like dave and
aaron who are just always paired
together
but
to me that this they're they're like an
old married couple and when they're when
they're in their most terrified like
pure
terror they're having they're bickering
with each other about
like dave's like you need to answer me
when i call you if you what the [ __ ] you
need to answer me because aaron goes
full sign he's catatonically silent for
a bit right and then uh and then aaron
breaks into the the bad room and he's
like dave i found a way out and dave's
of course like
yeah you of course you found a way out
there but that one that one there's
nothing's out there about that [ __ ] so
we'll just keep a lid on that one right
right right oh my god it's it's it's so
great yeah we tortured the guys
and like
we couldn't go out in public much so we
doubled down on the torture of like just
constantly
you know jackass is always some like
even i get ptsd after one of these
things right
i was curiously comfortable uh on you
know like the whole looking well figured
out like well it's [ __ ] man if i if they
get me i'm in the movie and if they
don't if i bust it then i just don't get
in the movie the only thing is that you
know that if your call time to arrive on
set is in the afternoon that
you'll figure that out
yeah
um
so when people ask me how did jackass
start oh man do i love this story wendy
up up
wendy it's bedtime bedtime
yeah
that's the one command that wendy really
knows it's bedtime because i love
snuggling with her in bed and i love it
so much more when that bed is from helix
sleep.com
telling me this is my favorite i've been
sleeping on my helix mattress for
what two years almost
i will never sleep on another mattress
that's all there is to it you know why
it's so great it's because when you go
to helix sleep.com you take this
two-minute quiz which just gets your
perfect mattress dialed in for exactly
what your needs are and they just get
you wait the best thing you can sleep on
and if you go to helixsleep.com
stevo you get up to 200 off any mattress
of your choosing plus they throw in two
free pillows and i'm telling you the
helix free pillows are the greatest man
they've got this
uh down alternative which is not cruel
my favorite pillows in the whole wide
world so get yourself a new mattress man
sleep better feel better go to
helixsleep.com
stevo and get that deal
now let's tell this story that i love
i've got this distilled like i say uh it
started we were making skateboarding
videos yeah
and they just had all this crazy stuff
in it these skateboarding videos and
then
they became very popular and the guy in
charge of making these skateboarding
videos reached out to his friend spike
jones and he said hey you know our
videos are getting so popular but
like
it's not the skateboarding that people
are freaking out over it's all this
other crazy stuff and i think if we
subtract the skateboarding then what's
left over could be a tv show and when
you took out the skateboarding from the
big brother videos what you were left
with was knoxville wee man pontius and
bam was doing something similar so it
was like it's a pretty good yeah it's a
skate video without a whole lot of
skating like well
big brother you know
to be clear we were the
our whole like right it was about
personality very thin veil it was about
personalities the bigger the big
personalities in skateboarding more so
than the great skateboarding that's
happening you know i mean like it was
much more about finding the characters
and so
i know that um
it's so funny how when jackass started
like there was still like i may do
dickhouse
is the production company responsible
for every
iteration of jackass and
when we started filming
the the tv show
like how clueless
to all levels of production like release
forms like you know we knew about
release forms i mean we knew about
release forms
we weren't very uh concerned about um
premise releases right uh
we weren't i did i knew we didn't have a
sound guy there was no sound guy there
was no sound guy in the first two
seasons in all the tv shows we never had
a sound guy like it was me taping a
microphone or something one or trip or
uh who even did that we put mics on a
lot of times
for pranks for pranks and and whatever
for sending somebody down the hill like
when you still box you had a [ __ ] mic
on you okay i don't even remember that
we hurt you guys a lot of times because
we didn't know where to put the [ __ ]
little metal box and when you fall on it
it sucks
and the sound was terrible i didn't know
that you could color correct
right so we were using
you know a couple of not i wouldn't call
professional cameras it was the pd-150
was our go-to camera which was a
professional-grade
dvr cam like it was somewhere in between
a skate camera it was better than the vx
1000 which was what all the skaters used
but it was the same camera just
it allowed for a better mic or more
right right slightly more professional
and then handheld straight out of the
[ __ ] best buy you know what i mean
i remember okay so
when uh i
i got so lucky that i i was fired from
like every job i had before jackass
because
when the pilot was going on for jackass
like i i if i hadn't been fired i would
have missed out on it because i was on a
cruise ship working as a clown is that
when we shot them yeah yeah but but i
got i got fired
uh from my cruise ship job and i walked
off and i had saved like 9 000 bucks
over my six months did you get fired or
you just didn't i got i i i
the the other clowns said to the the
brass of the cruise ship company they
said if stevo comes back for another
contract we all quit
you got pushed out yeah a bunch of
jealous clowns it was it was a clown
mutiny yeah
so uh so so and and i wasn't supposed to
know this i'd like like my boss clown he
said hey man i'm gonna tell you
something and if if it gets out that i
told you i'm going to lose my job but
i'm just not going to sit here and let
these clowns do you like this i'm
telling you up front like you're not
coming back for another contract they
all went behind your back and made this
happen so it's time for you to start
calling up your skateboard buddies and
try to get something and going with them
and so i knew ahead of time and i my
first call was to you i said jeff
i'm working on uh cruise ships as a
clown i'm always walking around on
stilts and it's like the biggest fear
i'm terrified while i'm walking on
stilts that that uh that i might fall
over
and so i gotta do it
you know i gotta do it and i'm thinking
that if
i if i'm on stilts and i've got a big
still costume we set it on fire then i
can have a unicycle you know i did this
whole thing
and uh i bought all the
[ __ ] equipment that's still costumes
made all this all the equipment
none of the really none of the fireproof
equipment that you would want to use in
a situation like
right i bought three sets of uh of stilt
clothes
like ten foot tall clothing costumes
and we we set them all on fire i you
know i got this stealth i bought my
airplane tickets like i i [ __ ] spent
all the money i'd saved to go out to try
to be in big brother magazine
and
and i didn't even know and so i get out
there and you're like okay now i'll tell
you this is for a pilot from tv right it
was just me ballard and uh
i was there knoxville was there yeah
yeah and but it was like uh
[ __ ] amazon after loudoun's [ __ ]
crazy rewards
what's their deal does it always sound
like that it's a new it's kind of a new
thing nothing
um
cesar you want to record
it's all good man
i gotta reel myself in and let you
[ __ ] tell stories
what's that
i have this thing where like if i can
bring guests on so i can
tell that story
we have a long story past
yeah yeah let me not let that i'm gonna
let that
amazon truck like a be my reminder to
reel myself in
um but uh bear can start so it was
balanced
you know and i'll pass it over to you
once uh what does that thing
it's uh
the battery for
a whoop strap a what a whoop strap the
most sophisticated fitness tracking
device known to man are they going to be
a sponsor on this
you might as well just drop it right now
it's just pure that that's data that's
coming in goes through
yeah it goes to your phone and that's
just a battery charger so there's no
waterproof it's just pure right it is
there it'll be like oh we noticed you
were meditating do you mind if we add
that to your list and you're like how
the [ __ ] knight doesn't know about
meditating but if i get on a bicycle it
automatically knows i'm riding a bicycle
um okay so it was just bad just said
that it was just balanced i don't
remember it was just ballard
did ricko i think maybe we had rick i
don't remember i don't remember too much
about i remember you went down to danny
ways yeah yeah um and that was the first
day i ever met knoxville this happened
on december 30th of 1999. we're yeah so
we you guys didn't know what jackass was
either right we didn't even we didn't
even i don't think had the pilot deal
done i think this is pre-pilot to be
honest we were just gathering [ __ ] like
you were in town you wanted to do some
[ __ ] so we went and [ __ ] shot it
and uh
they did not so sat me down on a
hay bale and interviewed me
right right we didn't yeah we didn't
we didn't know what jackass was well
into filming jackass we still didn't
know right how is it gonna like well
doing the pilot we knew
uh [ __ ] it doesn't require a host right
yeah because we were at first like all
right we had these big brother videos
that people loved
and then
we got the tv show based on just cutting
together the funniest bits from those
some of them [ __ ] right and a couple
other things off of like whiskey i think
i don't remember where i just sourced a
bunch of crazy [ __ ] but it all looked
like
jackass like uh
and and so we then we get the pilot like
we sell it to mtv
and we don't know how to we don't know
what it is still we're like we showed
this sizzle tape that they loved right
and then now we got the deal now we're
going to make a pilot all right do we
put knoxville behind a desk and you know
we're talking about we start thinking tv
you know like it should be a tv show
and what we showed isn't a tv show
that's just a skate video right right
and then like so we start talking about
this and then spike just shut us out
he's like no just it just that's what it
is
you know what i mean you know what it is
it's great and so like he helped us like
gain confidence of stop thinking like
it's a tv show
it's just we sold it this is what it is
spike's like
got this annoying habit of being right
yeah like i'm not going to say that
spike's right 100 of the time but i
strongly believe that when you knoxville
and spike reach a consensus decision on
anything that it's bulletproof yeah
there's three we do have three different
yeah ways of looking at it like things
you know even on the opening like in in
in retrospect on the opening sequence of
jackass forever [ __ ] he was right he i
have proof he was right right and i was
adamantly i know i was on your side
hunkered into my position on it and i
was absolutely wrong
so i don't even pretend to know like my
taste leans a little more radical
towards your taste
and you're a bad guy
i it takes a lot to get me right
excited or grossed out or you know like
but yeah but i learned i've learned
along the way like no show it to people
get for sure watch them watch it and
base a lot of it on
yeah so pass to my [ __ ]
right
two cents because i've got bad judgment
me too i am not representative of my
demographic right
i i i i use a lot of bad judgment and i
need people around me that have better
judgment for sure
so you went to the same university as my
sister washington university in saint
louis right
and and what what were you doing there
communications no arts art school
art school yeah i was a painter
so that's the only way i got into school
was i i was a c
c c students straight c's in high school
didn't care about high school and while
she was like pretty hard to get into
school but the art school was your way
around the academics i had a really good
art portfolio going
big brother you were doing the i was
doing that i was the boss there like but
like i was the art director
editor-in-chief in the beginning that
was rocco and then
it was pretty much
when i got hired i was the boss to make
sure we make a magazine so i would hire
the writers and like and it turned out
that cliver mckee wrote a lot of the
[ __ ] and
that i'd farm out because i'd been
working and published i'd done a bmx
magazine i was the art director for bmx
magazine and that was where you linked
up with spike i think it was i went to
no i went to i knew spike since he's 12
like maryland from maryland yeah and
since he was 12. since he was 12. he
worked he got a job at the bike shop
that i used to work well i didn't work
that i used to ride for and
so we grew up together and i like so
when you used to ride for a bike shop
you were just kind of yeah i was like
shop sponsored-ish you know like
it's like like mountain bike i got to no
no bmx like uh i was a dirt jumper and a
ramp rider i was a vert writer
in the early this is like yeah 82
83 i don't know it was old like 81 i
don't remember like wow way back in the
day um
and uh okay so i heard a story about
like spike's so crazy you're driving on
the highway and he just like
just he's driving and then he dives into
the back seat oh my god
yeah like um so this is when we were
doing the bike like so spike got me the
job at freestyling magazine like i was
just graduating i would come out and
visit him on spring break when i was in
college the last two at least and
saw what they like it was just three
dudes making this [ __ ] great magazine
that i grew up looking at and i'm like
[ __ ] i wanna that's what i wanna do so
my senior year i just
revamped i just made the
design professor
uh she she helped me put a magazine
portfolio i could lay out a magazine
even though that i wasn't a graphic
design student i just shifted thinking i
want to do this
so i
took it on myself and didn't even get
grades on that [ __ ] like i was just
single working with my design professor
and it paid off because right as i was
graduating
they needed a new art director
but that's not the story anyway so then
i get hired and we're having a great
time making this [ __ ] bike magazine
and we were going down to shoot
uh do a photo spread with matt hoffman
and we're going from uh torrance to
san diego okay matt was going to be in
uh
there's i can't remember what the ramp
was but we were going to meet at a ramp
and we had the big air [ __ ] it was
before that way before that
and so we had a big so we're in a chevy
astrovan this is the company azerbaijan
it said freestyling down the side and uh
we had this a couple of bike boxes which
are big you know
shoved between the consoles so there was
the two captains seats and then it was a
cargo van and uh
well it was a cargo van that had not a
cargo man it just had seats but the bike
box was jammed right up against between
the two
front seats
and spike put the thing in cruise
control and we're shooting down the 405
heading towards the 5.
he's going 80. there's no traffic but
we're just flying down the uh
freeway and he's got in cruise control
and he's like hey can you hold the wheel
for one second so i hold the wheel and
he flips his seat back and back rolls
out and runs to the back of the van and
won't come back
and so i'm steering this thing and i
can't there's a [ __ ] bike box that's
wedged in right here that i can't just
slide over and get into that seat
without like you know i have to kind of
ghost ride i had to climb over and get
through that i'm not the most flexible
limber person to [ __ ] do that
but yeah he never came back he sat back
there and just was ready to die like he
says
that's crazy man [ __ ] he also like we
this is way later this is uh uh two
[ __ ] why don't we do it it was right
before jackass three but it was summer
it was when we did the um 24-hour
takeover of empty okay
we decided we're gonna film this um
tribute to evil knievel matt hoffman was
putting together this tribute to evil
knievel and we were trying to so spike
and knox when i go to oklahoma
and uh knoxville had rented a big um
crown vic
and spike flew in late like so he gets
there and we're on our way to the
location oh no this is the this is
leaving location that day where we
filmed a bunch of crazy stunts uh spike
says let me drive that he loves crown
vicks
so he takes knoxville gets him the keys
i'm right in the back seat knoxville
shotgun spike's driving rent a car crown
vic
and we're
about to get onto the freeway and he
looks
and there's it's like a clover like a
big looping uh ramp to get onto the
freeway
and there's a big mound almost like a
skate bowl
of dirt you know grass around that ramp
so we start
going in and then he just floors it and
rolls into the bowl off the ramp and
into the grass and start
like we're getting cheat out like like
just carving a bowl
in this crown vic
it's not 80 70. i don't know how bad it
was [ __ ] fast and as we're cruising
around all of a sudden
like you just hit something i don't know
if it was a dip or a rock i don't know
what but then we
skidded down and got onto the freeway
and we're cruising on the freeway and
we're just watching the temperature
gauge just start to
fly up
and spike look at that i'm like oh man
that's going fast it's like you can see
it move so we're like oh that's not good
and then the red lights start going and
then car starts like dying and dying
we're just driving it until we're not
even trying to
like pull over we're just trying to get
to where we need to go
and then the car seized and so then we
just left it on the side of the road and
we passed it every day for the next
three days because none of us were going
to call it in like until we flew home
and then shawna had to figure it all out
one of many vehicles yeah
and that was all spike right
um so
dude
we traveled the world together man
mm-hmm like uh i mean dude put it there
we did we wild
my dream job like like honestly like
that was me just
piling on like jackass was a huge
success we just made the first movie
yeah and uh
luckily mtv was like mtv was still
shocked that we wouldn't do the jackass
tv show anymore and so i said well
what i will do is
i want to do a nature show and you guys
need a nature show right
but we'll make it like a jackass nature
ship so it'll be
kind of like jackass but a nature show
which i don't know why i mean that's
just because that's all i watched like
that's all i wanted to do it was a
nature show yeah like steve irwin and
all that [ __ ] but
i got really lucky
because that was really you and pontius
yeah and and you guys that kind of let
me in on you yeah well we went it was so
funny because um like i i would just
watch animal planet or discovery channel
and one day chris was over
and we were watching and we saw this
yeah we watched manny like
jumping on shark like he and rackley are
riding in a little [ __ ] boat and
they're jumping out of the boat onto the
back of sharks and pulling the sharks
out of the water and these are legit
socks like bull sharks juice and uh
and managed doing it in a speedo and
like [ __ ] look at that like we gotta
find these guys so right uh
we tried to find them when you went with
the
nurse shark diving
we were we were looking for that dude
like i already knew about manny i didn't
know how to find him but we had gooch
and everybody trying to find this dude
and uh
finally we tracked him down and it was
when you did the worm trick it was the
next season of jackass we were back in
florida i remember that the first day of
the unicycle off the air boat right with
the gator right there
the warm up in their nose and
dude it was the first time we ever met
manny yeah we're at this everglades park
and we're in the parking lot just with
all you know getting the gear out
whatever knoxville's standing there
manny's standing there we see this
family walking in our direction and all
of a sudden their faces light up and
knoxville is like okay here we go this
is early on too so knox is still stoked
about getting recognized you know he's
like yeah and then they walk right
[ __ ] past knoxville to manny they're
like manny
and then uh and then it was and then
knoxville asked him i want to get bit by
a rattlesnake and manny says no no no no
no no yeah yeah and and that was when
i went on to learn if manny says like
something's not okay
it's not [ __ ] okay and if manny says
something is okay that doesn't really
matter
that just means he'd be there willing to
be there you know like and that got us
around like having uh to be under the
supervision of professionals like manny
was our professional right he was just
the key that unlocked anything we wanted
to do on wild boys god damn like i'll
tell you like so we went and uh
we were shooting jackass first jackass
movie and we were in florida and we had
manny and he's like jeff you need to
swim in the black swamp i'm like all
right well we'll do it we'll do it like
we're not no
it was me and chris went and swam with
that was really i remember the tv show
days though that was like the tv show it
was it was before it was uh black swan
midnight was after jackass one before
wild boys okay but this is during
jackass one
uh
we went on our day off me and chris went
and swam the swamp with manny
yeah jeff tremaine isn't just the
jackass director the dude's an absolute
maniac wait to hear about this day off
you know what i like to do on my day off
is really treat myself man and i am
happy to tell you that this little spot
comes from a brand new company which
makes my mornings so wonderful it's
called just
egg this is a totally healthy
cholesterol-free
plant-based
egg product they're coming through with
the fluffiest omelettes that you're
gonna eat all year man the best
scrambled eggs the most delicious
quiches and hey
full disclosure i eat eggs right i mean
i used to be totally vegan now i eat
eggs but dude since i tried just eggs i
like them way better man i'm telling you
my girl cooks him up and we have these
great breakfasts you just gotta look out
for this company just egg they've
actually got this ingredient
that lowers your cholesterol these uh
polyunsaturated fats i'm not even sure
all i know is that chicken eggs wish
they were this healthy i want to say
thank you to just egg for these
wonderful breakfasts that i have been
enjoying on my days off
now let's hear about jeff tremaine's day
off
and man he's just swimming down and
bringing the [ __ ]
ten foot alligators right in front of us
and they're mad and they they swim away
and it was scary [ __ ] but but we filmed
it and it was [ __ ] dude that's
[ __ ] epic that that's your day off
like when is your day off and then you
choose to go play with alligators in the
swamp yeah and so then i go back to
florida
after jackass
the first movie
and i called man he's like jeff
i want to go to the black swamp at night
i'm like oh [ __ ]
well what happens tonight well the
alligators hunt at night but let's just
go do this you know do the same [ __ ]
like like and so your visibility is bad
enough in the daytime so this is just
this is me
rack and manny yeah like and trusting
them to like you know i'm
i know how to snorkel i know how to like
but i'm not great at any of that like
i'm not super comfortable
you know just in in those [ __ ] guys
are they're ducks you know they're
they're yeah they're pure aquaman yeah
and uh
and they don't
have the best equipment
give me the i trusted them to have the
flashlights and everything somewhere
right we rack's got a camera he's got a
flashlight they give me my snorkel gear
they gave me a wetsuit
we go start swimming in the swamp at
night and i'm telling you you couldn't
see your [ __ ] hand in front of your
face pitch black i mean there's no moon
nothing and we get in the water
and we get in the water and then manny
starts [ __ ] swimming away
and i'm swimming with this [ __ ]
flashlight you can only see whatever the
beam of light it's like holding a
lightsaber underwater right and every
now and then you pass over a big garfish
or a turtle or something and you're like
holy [ __ ] i'm and then i'm thinking i've
got this little red snorkel tip and i
keep flipping back thinking there's i'm
getting tracked
they think i'm a duck they think my
head's a [ __ ] duck and i'm gonna get
bit in the head by an alligator and so i
keep flipping back and also you're
hitting branches and i'm like oh the
snake slips sleeping on top of that
branch i'm just [ __ ] scared to death
and luckily man um and mark and manny go
off trying to bring alliances they think
i need to see an alligator now and so
they swim up ahead so i'm just by myself
with this light while they're charging
and of course manny comes back with a
10-foot alligator and [ __ ]
lets it go right like it fights itself
like you can if you're gentle with them
you can bring it back it's got like
loose skin underneath yeah
and they have no concept of what's going
on so they don't feel threatened and
manny stays out of the eye line but he
lets this [ __ ] big ass aligner go
right next to me and i'm floating
and it swam and hits both my legs
swimming away and i'm like did i get bit
i don't know what like this big powerful
animal just whacked me in the leg
getting away from us and i'm like and
then my light goes out
i feel like you're describing the
silence of the lamps i'm telling you
like it was and i'm with mark and manny
who are just like
uh yeah
so brave so gnarly but like
ill-prepared we were totally
ill-prepared to be in there we got some
cool footage like sure and and that was
that was a day off yeah that was a that
was vacation did you count how many
countries we went to on wild boys we
went to no i don't we went to every
continent except antarctica and we tried
to go to antarctica we it was really
hard to do
it's a little one-dimensional too i
think it would have been cool i think
south georgia island would have been
cool you know we looked we totally
looked into it but it was that's been
he's got a way to get to yeah it was
like for us it was a
ship we had to get on
and go from at the bottom of argentina
and the problem is it was
paying for the whole crew and everybody
right like a week just to go for a few
days and back and really supervised by
not what wild boys was looking for as
far as the scientists and the right
right very supervised very hands-off
approach to which is great but that's
not what worked for us right
um i mean dude they did did you get
extra pages added to your passport yeah
yeah i had the fattest [ __ ] passport
and it's [ __ ] possible i still have
it it's the best it's totally still
happening do you have three holes poked
in it because yeah yeah yeah
yeah
yeah oh man my new passports are so
boring compared to that one yeah oh dude
have you ever told the story about uh
new orleans and and uh getting hit in
the head with a bike lock
like a d-shaped bike lock i don't know
why
i don't know if i doesn't remember i
remember oh no i clearly remember yeah
like no it was just some shady character
there was a guy like so we got to the
hotel bar we we were in new orleans oh
yeah this is right after fresh after
well katrina was august we're there in
february right right and so
i
we were staying right on the french
quarter it was dead at night like there
was only a few places open and because
like they were
like it was so devastated by katrina
still that there was like more of a
crime element than there had been
previously as i understand it and
because of that we had armed security
with us
like we actually had security guards
like you know with us at night and so
this guy
they weren't with us me that night but
they were like right we left them like
at some point the security guard was
there yeah he was there when we first
saw this guy so we were at the hotel bar
and this guy's like
so you're rich by me because you're rich
buy me a drink i'm like [ __ ] that
says i did i got you a white russian but
i might have come did it yeah and then i
don't know
but yeah i remember you said that a word
for it i got you a white russian but i
might have [ __ ] in it and i go up to
this dude and [ __ ] straight shove him
across the the lobby like into the arms
of the security guy right
you know like every time i ever had
security it just got me into trouble
make sure that like it's like whenever
we bring an ambulance on set well if
we're paying for that ambulance we're
going to use that goddamn neighborhood
so i shoved this i shoved this guy into
the security he grabs him and just leads
him out of the hotel but then that was
like oh well now now we've made a thing
with these guys right so they [ __ ]
see you later on in the night well bam
bam flies in late that night and so we
get there and uh
it was i don't know it was late like
three o'clock in the morning two o'clock
in the morning the teddy bear and the
guy uh it was some bar or like just
random bar and uh
and this guy starts [ __ ] with bam and
bam wasn't there earlier so he didn't
i'm like oh [ __ ] that's that [ __ ] guy
again
and
and we're just drinking trying to calm
it down like his buddy comes and tries
to calm and make it cool
and i was i appreciated that
and then i look and [ __ ] bam and that
dude are fighting out outside i'm like
oh [ __ ] so i run out of fighting like
really fast like yeah like bam's got his
finger in his mouth damn's got the
dude's finger in it bam's mouth biting
him and so i'm like oh [ __ ] so i run out
and as soon as i run out right bam's
biting the finger bam's biting the guy
who
asked you to buy him a drinks finger
it's all your fault and uh and i run out
to break up the fight and right when i
run out i get hit over the head with a
you know like a kryptonite style bike
lock yeah
and and uh the guy behind me who was
working on our crew got hit over that he
got his ear whacked and his back he got
t he got hit twice this guy was swinging
this thing and it was the guy who tried
to make it cool it was the buddy
he was swung the [ __ ] bike lock and i
didn't even think i got hit and it felt
like someone was pouring coffee over my
head it felt like hot water was it was
just blood just running down my [ __ ]
absolute blood bath yeah and then you go
to the hospital and you ask the doctor
can you do your own stitches i just
wanted a cool scar like i was never hurt
it was like it was so weird that i would
push on it and i was drunk but i wasn't
that way like i was aware right i was
like [ __ ] why doesn't this hurt this is
weird there's a gash you know big old
[ __ ] gash that was gushing blood but
but i talked to the doctor i'm like
listen i'm
i'm artistic
and i think i could do this can you just
supervise me and let me do this artistic
not autism
artistic i'm creative like i'm i'm
talented at [ __ ] like i can i can do it
like i think i could do my own stitches
because it didn't hurt yeah i can maybe
shoot some novocaine in there just make
sure but like and she was not having not
this this we had it took us forever to
find a hospital like right three of the
hospitals were closed derek had to get
out and come find me and get me to the
hospital and so it's derrick and shawna
and me
and
and i'm just like all right listen you
won't let me do it i get it
you're telling me it's a you think it's
gonna be ten stitches but can you just
do it in five do it in five
i want something to shuffle you can't
even [ __ ] see it like there's nothing
there she did such a nice job and she
had so little patience do it in 5.
i'm like i want a scar like i mean don't
get it like do a shitty job just make it
work like i don't care i don't want to
get infected but like do not make it
nice dude wait what i'm loving about
this this conversation so much like in
the big picture of it is that it's that
it's really coming across
that like
oh and he's not just oscar nominated
right he won him he won an oscar right
is he academy yeah academy award-winning
director spike jones is actually this
[ __ ] gnarly dude you know and like
and the most like
can be super sensitive
like people think of him she's really
sensitive and nice
and yet he's the one that will right
like whenever he comes on set right he
makes you do [ __ ] you never thought you
like he pushes it right further right
and he is he is super uh
empathic he's super empathic and and
then like here you know the director
like
like on your day off like oh i'm you
know like it's it's it reminds me of
like the old [ __ ] rogaine thing i'm
not just the hair club
i want to be like i showed up to work
that next day like with the karate kid
call time was seven i think i got there
at 7 15. straight from the hospital too
the dad did uh and we shot that's when
we shot we men getting blown across the
airbus the airboat and uh and dunn
riding on top of the van where we tried
to do the
wolves but he was on waterskiing and he
landed in like ankle deep water like
was that oh man
it's so it's just so rad the [ __ ] the
like the legacy man yeah like
did you see how in um like the knoxville
had his article on gq magazine and they
just you know talked to me for uh like
you know quotes or whatever and i said
dude like when when i found out
knoxville wanted to do a fourth jackass
movie after a 10-year hiatus
i was like
no dude like we [ __ ] i mean not no
but my concern was that we had gotten
away with so much and we had we had this
this fantastic legacy and then now all
it would take would just be one [ __ ]
stupid accident one [ __ ] stupid thing
and and like it would all be out the
window you know like being like oh a lot
of these guys where were just [ __ ]
[ __ ] and now knoxville's in a
wheelchair [ __ ] some weird thing to
just ruin everything and uh it reminds
me of when i asked you what would happen
if the shark bit me when i had the fish
hook through my face i'm like dude we
were hours away from the shore of
hurricane devastated louisiana like what
would happen if the shark bit me and you
said
i don't know man we got god
and like and then once again dude we
made a fourth jackass movie and like
like so much to lose you know i'm like
dude we've survived so much we've
like gotten away with so much we've got
this beautiful legacy and we're gonna
put it all on the line and like you
weren't as distracted as i was like said
knoxville i went to lunch with him uh
this is before you found out and uh
and he's like hey man i
think i want to
and that's the first time he's ever been
the one that like it's usually that goes
to him and says hey i think right you
know you're you're showing up on wild
boys right one on wild boys
you've shown up ready to die on wild
boys why don't we make another movie
tonight
like if you're gonna take a bullet like
let's do it on a movie screen not on the
tv that was how jack got let's let's
tell that story the last trip we ever
went on for wild boys i think it was
understood that it would be the last
trip or not no well no
no okay but it ended up being the last
trip doesn't russia yeah our last trip
was to russia and oh boy was there a
[ __ ] was that a wild trip we brought
knoxville yeah we brought nonchalant it
was a wild trip so we had this one day
of filming with like
what was it like what do you mean it was
a wild trip
like the russian secret service where we
went to a terrorist group we went to
some yeah special ops who knows what the
[ __ ] they were they were
they were gnarly trained russian
assassins basically and they had a nine
millimeter gun with rubber bullets in it
yeah they had a [ __ ] attack dog they
had this [ __ ] and noxus says
shoot me with the [ __ ] nine
millimeter rubber bullet while the dog
attacks me well they they wanted to
scare us
you know they didn't get it like they
they thought that they set up like a
little obstacle course where you were
supposed to run around and run by the
scary dog as it's like it's some big-ass
massive type weird yeah i've never seen
that dog before like a giant
dangerous dog that's on a chain and
that's like well i want to get bit by
that i'm like
i'm not not just like don't just let the
dog bite the dog to bite me but shoot me
while i wanted to have a shootout with
rubber bullets but they weren't trying
they weren't they didn't think they were
going to [ __ ] shoot and i'm like
and then i was able to get there and
knocks was just ready to die like
[ __ ] bit by the dog get stopped by
the [ __ ] at the same time i remember
yeah we've had some issues with the
rubber bullets like yeah that's not
neces they call it less lethal
i've never been around those rubber
bullets but they were shot out of a nine
mil so we did you know he's like shoot
me i'm like well let's do some testing
like we did with this like back in the
day somebody less lethal i haven't
removed the word lethal
do you know you know the story about the
first time we ever shot like
the beanbag i wasn't there you weren't
there like we it didn't air because i
made the guy test like we found some
stunt guy that was willing to do it
and so he ended in there
like this is not on the first movie this
is before the this is from
tv show all right knoxville goes online
and buys these little [ __ ] beanbag
bullets
so we we if you don't mind just it's
non-sequitur out of russia uh
he went online
and found
um
yeah beanbag beanbag boat so he buys a
shotgun he buys three shells uh-huh like
that have the bean bag packed in the
show like and we're trusting that this
is like yeah cool we've just found a
stuntman that's willing to use a shotgun
and shoot him
with it
and so now we're gonna shoot this for a
tv show cool um
and then we get there and i start like
this is me for the first time probably
using good judgment i'm like alright
well wait a minute
we don't know what these things do
like i'm just trusting that this is a
shotgun shell and it's going to shoot a
[ __ ] right bean bag so i'm like all
right
tell you what let's we we've got a
watermelon we set a watermelon up yeah
shoot the watermelon
[ __ ] blows right through the
watermelon right through the plywood
behind it
like
wow
holy [ __ ] like that through you know
three-quarter inch plywood hole right
through it like that beanbag did
like hold on so then
put two more sheets of plywood
shoot drew target on the plywood shoot
that
first of all
it doesn't hit the target it goes near
the target
but blows right through three sheets of
plywood this little [ __ ] beanbag i'm
like you can't i'm not gonna
yeah we have one more shell thank god we
had the two shells were practiced now
we're down to the one and knoxville like
well we're here let's just do it
i'm like are you [ __ ] kidding like
did you did we see the same thing i
filmed it
you know there's a hole in three sheets
of plywood and a watermelon that doesn't
didn't even blow the watermelon up it
just went right through the watermelon
and right through the plywood there's
like a little hole
like a [ __ ] gun bullet not a you know
how you expect it to blow
yeah like the worst kind like
because these things fly like little
frisbees these are the early days
right yeah bean bags like if you shot
somebody that's gonna go right in them
so what made it okay when it was time to
do the movies you didn't do it that day
we didn't do that day
we found a more legit company
that shot a bigger projectile that had a
tail the tail made it a little more
accurate still not accurate like it's
crazy that they [ __ ] shoot these
things at people like it's crazy because
they don't go where they're supposed to
i don't know if they've gotten better
since but when we did jackass one right
we were able to do it and uh but we had
a professional
it had to go through a lot of safety
measures and we did we had plenty of
them to do the testing and all that so
but i called it off and knoxville was
still willing and he was mad at me when
we walked away without the footage like
he's so gnarly [ __ ] like why are you
willing to do that like that's not we
don't need the footage that bad like
this is the difference
and then when we're in rush the same
thing like just well we're here let's
get the footage i'm like can we just run
around and get scared by this [ __ ] and
not get that footage today because i i
don't i think this is gnarlier than
right and if you're mtv2 right
and so like right when we got home i'm
like [ __ ]
if you still have this in like you
clearly
want to go
do this [ __ ] but you came out for
nothing to shoot with us and right
russia let's do another one and he was
like yeah i'm ready and so that was
jackass 2. i don't remember exactly what
happened on jackass 3 but it was the
same amount of time it passed it feels
like the right amount of jackass 3 was
that
a lot of us had
traded in certain vices
and uh
and and replaced them with with
healthier things knoxville's
just
became addicted to
nut shots
that was during jackass three right
right right that's
we've done the 24-hour takeover you just
come out of surprise like this
i was getting shot with [ __ ] oranges
out of some [ __ ] crazy high power
cannon with matt hoffman in spain
and he said
uh tremaine's trying to do a third
jaguars movie and i was like really he
says that's what he says you know so i
think that was all you yeah um
and dude but then he pulls me aside and
says i'm ready to do i'm like are you
kidding and then he pulls out a notebook
with like
like
full of [ __ ] that he'd been just
gathering for the last 10 years like
he's just such a different breed of dude
i guess we all are
um
the uh
when we were doing wild boys and
presumably
like jackass and then maybe even with
the movies as well like you've always
got like in your director
mind the idea that when you submit
the edit of the episode that there's
gonna be some pushback on like the
powers that be in putting it out whether
that's mtv's standards and practices if
it's the mpaa the motion picture
association they're going to watch it
and they're going to say hey you can't
include this certain thing and actually
started way back in big brother brother
red herring we call them red herrings
yeah we learned early on that like
to get what we want we have to kind of
go further
for some reason it's a negotiation like
it's not just
black and white you can't do this you
can't do that right it's subjective it's
subjective and we're dealing with people
so
we learned oh well let's just cut it out
load it up with the gnarly [ __ ] over the
top [ __ ] and big brother we used to
submit you know crazy pictures that we
knew weren't going but they would see
him and said you can't do that you can't
do that right and then the thing we
wanted looked way less
radical and like all right well can we
keep that one as long as you get rid of
these three you can keep that one got it
right and
that was that was it was always like
part of our like production schedule
shooting like oh let's do this for a red
we should not be i mean like it's just
gonna shoot me i've i've talked about it
before but it really just shoots us in
the foot when we expose
and we can can we do this no leave it
i'm just saying like it's stuff
we had a huge one on the new movie was
just like we loaded it
and
they they singled out all the shots that
we knew weren't going
and
left alone the ones i didn't even have
to negotiate it was like
because we put in
six minutes of just pure [ __ ] filth
knowing that this right
less
filthy filth would get through so so and
we've always had like in both jackass
and wild boys it's always we've had this
love affair with mascot costumes it was
like the the night monkeys the the the
pandas
you know like we did a lot of it and
when we were in russia even though i
don't think it was an animal that was at
all into no it was pandas that were not
indigenous to china yeah no you were it
was polar polar bears in in russia which
yeah it made sense okay maybe there was
pandas in japan which didn't that was
loomis's idea today anderson
so with the the the p the polar bear
suits in russia and always with these
costumes it was like a montage bit you
know it would be music driven and like
cut together this montage and so the
note came back from the standards and
practices department when you submitted
the russia episode and they said
um please
strike meaning please remove
the shot of
the polar bears getting
[Applause]
[Laughter]
legitimately to pay for hookers
we cut
we cut uh holes in the the polar bear
costume to make for our wieners to come
out
we had these big gigantic polar bear
heads to be clear
jp came out to direct that bit and he
was really good at like directing that
kind of [ __ ]
[Applause]
do you find that you have like
it's hard to like
when stories start coming out to just
not top like we have so many [ __ ]
crazy stories like when you start
digging into the the wild boys
the greatest there's
there's actually a few of the greatest
photos ever taken yeah
you're in i think three of them
the greatest photo ever taken and
deleted i mean dude that was the
greatest photo ever taken by the way
that was so much funnier than the the
front flip over right i would tell this
story like like we're in indonesia
and i was i was heartbroken because i
had i had lost
what was at that time the love of my
life
and uh and we were super sympathetic
yeah i was i was i was heartbroken
and and somehow i just ended up drunk
and i was just like nah you know i'm
trying to get over it and here i meet
this
this lady of the night at the at this
bar in indonesia
and and
and i bring her back to my hotel room
and here i am and i'm i'm just having
sex with this this is your first time
with a hooker correct
my first time with the hooker was after
gumball rally oh okay so second second
time
in my head when i tell the story's your
first time with the hookers i mean the
first time with my first time with a
hooker in indonesia
and uh
and and i'm here i'm having you know sex
with this hooker and all of a sudden
let me tell this let me take over
because like so stevo like we're in this
little shitty ho we're on some island i
don't remember where borneo right now
somewhere and
it's like shitty little hotel and we
know what stevo's up to and we're all
[ __ ] wasted so it's me pontius
dimitri
uh
i don't think knoxville climbed in there
um
cordell
uh
we're all
gathered around and we sneak into your
room you're having sex in a pitch black
room your pitch black room i had never
no idea and we [ __ ] stealthily pick
your lock or just i don't think the room
was like we open the door and we crawl
in on this pitch black floor while
you're just [ __ ] away on the bed
and then
we're all in the room
and then dimitri stands up and hits a
flash photo i thought the photo was
taken from outside no right in the room
right
photo and we're all thumbs up
and you're [ __ ] on the bed with your
eyes glowing like lividly mad
and uh
and we take the flash goes off and then
like it like and we run out both out of
this room and you are [ __ ] livid
and we all run and try to hide and you
come tearing in like [ __ ] all right
so i i could do this damage control and
i have to promise you that i'll delete
the photo and then you proceed to go
back to your room and tear it apart
piece delay limb for living oh dude yeah
i destroyed this full molly crew in the
room retaliation i mean i was just
acting out i was drunk i was like man
like i i was i was philosophically
trying to get over this this love of my
life we were also coming off of like a
really hard
like gnarly this was a very gnarly 29th
street shooting days yeah gnarly
shooting schedule the day i got home i
got arrested on an airplane
right so what you're smoking chain
smoking
oh that was the yeah yeah dude i gotta
make a video for that just just and then
and then and that was the photo and so
we then we and then we we we go and we
are just dying laughing over this photo
i mean this photo is
the flash went off perfectly you're
but you and are looking looking at us
but with red eyes like so it looks
demonic and then pontius is standing up
like just thumbs up
like uh it is the funniest [ __ ]
picture in
and like i go and they like then i have
to go like then i'd go break the new we
had looked at the picture then you came
in furious i had a promise we'll delete
the picture
and then i go to dimitri and he's like
jeff don't make me delete this picture
steve was going to want this picture i'm
like no man
he made me promise that i delete the
picture and he's like
i do want it
he was absolutely right like and he's
like he's right don't make me delete
this picture you're going to regret it
and i'm like no you have to delete it
i mean no i watched him delete it he
didn't have time what's that
and you know how much is the
we have the story we have the story but
that photo was so [ __ ] like
you would have loved that picture matt
like yeah i mean if we were gonna say
top three gnarliest things that happen
on the road i mean it's a tough it's a
big bag to pull out oh god well but uh i
mean that we can talk about
yeah that we can talk about how about
when we were on shark week and we got
poopies and his dad meet with my dad
we're having this oh my god that was so
fun and the story's coming out in front
of my dad and poopy's dad and you were
driving it to be clear
but once you gave the green light to
tell like we told some of the filthiest
[ __ ] stories
yeah yeah
think poopy stuff was like what the [ __ ]
yeah it was it was a night in in uh
bombay
and and i
bombay india
also known as mumbai we're at this bar
and i meet this uh
this russian or not no sorry this
canadian lady at the bar she's like yeah
come on back tomorrow i'm like oh it's
on come on come on back to the
to be clear she was my friend's friend
oh really that's why she was there oh
damn she was your friend's friend and
she was married and she was married and
she was just a canadian expat living in
bombay india so i'm like all right [ __ ]
man i come back to
to go back to her place
where we
oh and i was with one other person from
the crew it was me and another guy from
the crew right and so we're like kind of
all getting down you know like we're
kind of and i wasn't even
so she's servicing this other guy from
the crew and pretty high up in the crew
you know like like uh
and and in the in this woman's bedroom
it's this woman's on her knees this this
crew members standing up all of a sudden
the bedroom door opens and it's her
husband well we don't know it's the
husband
yeah i mean
the guy is opening up the door to his
own bedroom and it is her husband and uh
i say we don't know right to be clear
this is not me right yes not you
this this this this crew member
the door opens the crew member says
dude get the [ __ ] out of here
it's in his own bedroom
and and the guy says hey man it's cool
i'll just watch and then the crew member
says
no dude it's not [ __ ]
get the [ __ ] out of here
you were the only witness to that and
that we quoted that forever no dude it's
not [ __ ] cool were you laughing out
of here i'm just like i mean i can't
even remember i mean i don't know i'm
just like i couldn't even believe it and
then and then the crew member in in in a
fit of frustration she's just like ah
[ __ ] i'm out of here and he takes off
so then like opportunity knocks for
steve
so i started getting getting in on it
and uh and i'm totally cool with the guy
watching like it was very hard he came
back in after the other guy left
he got kicked out of his own bedroom but
then when steve went he's like hey dude
it's cool
yeah i'm like dude it's cool
and it's very hard to get weed in india
yeah so so and this guy had weed so his
wife was servicing me while he's holding
this pipe up to my lips and lighting
jesus
and then and then he's like hey if you
want to have sex with my wife you know
like uh i i'll give you a condom and i'm
like right on dude so
it was the first time i ever had sex
with a bro with a married woman there
were certain lines i never crossed like
i never took anyone's virginity i had up
to that point never
i've been a part of adultery mm-hmm
yeah
and he got you weed
be high and i burned his wife while he
watched with the rubber that he gave
that's pretty gnarly yeah and then i got
back hopefully his rubber was better
than yours then i got back to the hotel
room at the sun's up and and i can i was
sharing a room with jp i and jb i'll
remember this forever because i walked
and i go jp i've been to bad places and
i've done bad things
that's crazy
remember we used to share rooms like
isn't that so crazy like uh even like
back in the old jackass days remember
like first time we shot with you was in
florida yeah and um
first
trip had been rooming with you and it
was a little much for tripp so he made
little nate end up staying with you
and that was when you hooked up with the
daytona rat and nate was pretending to
be asleep but you were going to town and
then um
and used a condom but then took that
condom off and threw it over towards
nate ah dude i i laid a used rubber on
scott potastic's face while i was asleep
yeah i mean dude we could be here all
day
i had a question where do you where do
you draw the line at like getting mad
for certain things and like if steve
destroys a hotel room on the road you're
too clear that hotel room ended up
costing a thing 200 bucks 200 americans
okay but then but then when they destroy
a van you're on camera just ripping
their [ __ ]
the van
that van was yeah that was i wasn't
there by the way when the van happened
because i was concussed from we we
smartly through our wrap party the night
before our big opening sequence shoot
and so like yeah i got lit up at the
[ __ ] wrap party they remember that i
got choked out by the bouncer and
dropped off my head
so i was concussed and in no shape to be
there and you guys destroyed
uh what turned out to be a team's a
teamsters van which is really bad
yeah it's cool to destroy rental van
like but right teamsters was we were a
little tricky but
i i never even got mad at it because i
didn't i wasn't in any condition they
kept calling me and i'm like [ __ ] i
don't know what to do yeah i mean i mean
did you see my video i made about the
like the the most expensive things i
ever destroyed yeah no but i used all
the van footage
and and the three cabins we burned down
in south africa
i used that footage oh my god
[ __ ] the three cabins that's the best
story too
oh my god isn't that is that one of the
photos it's so funny because tripp
tore you a new one
on the van on the van and we were we
were doing so you didn't total the van
you just ripped the interior up
maybe
yeah that's true you're completely dead
and then i remember i was up we were
right and then this was on the way to go
from the end of the the
jacket the
opening season all of us says the big
shopping cart oh no the old man that's
right that's right
the closing sequence of jackass comes in
chip comes into this room to just
[ __ ] let us have it and we're all
already done up as old men
he's yelling at like
this shoot's gonna get canceled like
you'd knight old man you [ __ ] you
know you guys have done it this time add
the medic
dude add the magic man i like my man had
some show like uh
his son came up i think he said my dad
was at the medic dude he really enriched
his life you know like he's since passed
but uh but his son was grateful all
right we could be here all day man but
let's remind everybody that fingers
crossed and maybe fingers not crossed
like
whenever this [ __ ] movie yeah
wait like it if and when when you hear
this the movie's coming out soon right
like i mean
we're we're going to get this up
hopefully
hopefully it comes out february 4th and
there's no way it
remains to be seen but but i texted you
um i texted you about a week or two ago
i said is this movie gonna really come
out until you said i'd be shocked
if it didn't come out on february 4th i
would be shocked still but uh
it's grim right now
it's gnarly
all i know is that we made a [ __ ]
unbelievable movie yeah i'm super proud
of this and like and proud of you for
like [ __ ] everyone just stepped up so
big it's so fun
so it's it's a fantastic [ __ ] movie
and and i find myself
like i call you paw in textiles like
thanks paw like you're like this pseudo
father figure to me you know
knox is kind of like an older brother
and you're like a dad figure and like
your opinion
you know like i hold
like my own dad like like what what you
think and your approval your praise you
knock so spike like they're they're
who spike
mom kind of right like yeah well he's
more like
the rich granddad
like john the getty figure but spikes
usually get the the better sense like
that yeah you know like for sure but but
i just like we've we've decades now you
know
decades of just this unbelievable
lightning in a bottle man like there's
no relationship we do need to at some
point put a book together with all of us
just to really
if everyone would let those stories fly
because there's something i've got a
knoxville story there they're here we
all we all have
a knoxville story i've got i've got jp
stories i've got wee man stories i've
got yeah i've got my own stories in
nairobi
but yeah dude i did do you want us to
drive anybody anywhere for oh i asked
one the one last question
i was divesting to know this because
jackass has been so uh like kind of few
and far between you know it's been very
sparse
you know like three movies over 20 years
but that's big box office revenue
and then you've got ridiculousness which
you created
and it's like
basic cable money for mtv which is much
less money
but it's been steady
just chugging along for over a decade
so
in the big picture what's been more
personally profitable for you
ridiculousness or jackass
they've both done me very well
like uh but i've done a lot of stuff to
be honest i've done a lot of commercials
i did a lot of i
just airline i stay busy i don't care
airlines is that really your thing every
time every time you're on the plane
that's my thing to me that was the
funniest one like i just wanted that so
bad because
i couldn't picture why am i being up for
this job like who got like you know the
ad agency had to pitch to american
airlines hey we think we have the
perfect director for safety
the guy who did jackass you know like
that's who we should get like dad yeah
now you've definitely done a lot of
that's probably been the most scene
thing i've ever done to be honest like
i see it every week think about it it's
been
six years on every flight
every flight okay for six years possible
and then it came out when you used to
have to watch you uses on every screen
right like yeah all right like 400
flights a day per day more than 400
flights a day
american airlines oh yeah how many is
the biggest airline in the world it's
biggest area in the world they're doing
thousands of flights a day like yeah
yeah okay i'll give you that um
lots of thousands yeah billions
billions of people have seen it yeah you
got motley crude the dirt was a big one
they haven't like a
bad trip as the trip wasn't built maybe
the most viewed yeah it was a big one
that got a lot of eyeballs on it yeah
for sure that's the only thing you've
made that you know for sure obama
watched
um but but but you don't you couldn't
guess which one ridiculous which one i
made more money off
he knows he just doesn't want to tell
you that
i've done well with both of those those
are
all right well and then there we have it
i mean we could we could do this every
week
we should do a part two whatever yeah
every month at one point we should dad
love you paul i love you too buddy
thanks man super proud of you i'm super
proud of this man like
it's it's a hit just just all of it just
this though it's just so awesome to
watch you do it man well thanks man you
know i candidly i know like absolutely
what a douche i am when i'm i'm always
barraging you and spike and knoxville
with texts to just guys look what i
pulled off look at it and i'm just
trying to like
just show off for you because i'm so
like proud of like whatever my latest
accomplishment is and i barraged you
with it and i know it's annoying and i
know it's douchey i don't i don't get
annoyed with i just i'm not a good text
friend like you clearly know i'm just
shitty about response but like i love it
and i love when i do watch them like i
always get so i'm like [ __ ] that was
awesome i try to only send stuff if i
think it's i'm really proud of it if i
think it's impressive and there's been a
lot of stuff that i'm really proud of
and i think is impressive lately and
it's fun to be on a roll and i just i
love watching you just the same you're
just like me
no idle hands man no i don't have those
we're doers yeah if i can make [ __ ]
happen like yeah i don't care what it is
i make [ __ ] that's all i want to do yeah
and i love it too man i love that that
you're always willing to to check out my
[ __ ] give me feedback and i love that uh
there's not a whole lot of like oh my
god this one [ __ ] you know like i'm
making good [ __ ] you're making great
[ __ ] like yeah you figured it out you
found your voice and you're damn super
stoked man well likewise dude i love you
being a [ __ ] boss dude and you always
have been and
i'm hot on your heels
thank you
[ __ ] yeah
right on
all right very cool awesome
we got a piece so bad
yeah dude
so there are so many stories so many
[ __ ] stories
like we didn't even finish it we just
kept jumping
man i really mean it that i could have
just sat there and told stories with
jeff tremaine
forever and and maybe we'll do another
podcast with him but right now
i mean [ __ ] is this movie coming out or
what
just yesterday there was over a million
coveted cases
and [ __ ]
right here in montana where i did the
show tonight in this theater clearly
they have no covet paul just go ahead
and put
the end of that show on here
[Applause]
i mean it's a crazy time to be alive man
and uh
it's an exciting time too thank you for
sticking around street team yeah dude